Suzel ici avec sa petite fille est
enseignante elle est également la
présidente de réunion Alzheimer une
association dont l'objectif est de
réunir et aider les familles notamment
est atteint de cette terrible maladie il
serait plus de 800 à la Réunion la
maladie d'Alzheimer dont souffrait sa
mère lui permet aujourd'hui d'en parler
et d'agir
notre mère a été prise en charge pendant
beaucoup d'années par notre Père qui est
qui s'occupait d'elle de façon
permanente bon nous notre rôle a été de
le soutenir d'être là
de faire intervenir donc des gens à
domicile pour de soulager mais il a
souffert énormément de de
la solitude quoi par rapport à ça parce
que
en fait il avait aucun moyen de
de d'être soulagé totalement et maman ne
pouvait pas être
mis chez les uns ou chez les autres ça
ne peut pas le faire ça pour un malade
Alzheimer de le déplacer de le mettre
deux jours chez un deux jours chez
l'autre il a besoin en permanence de de
repères donc si on le bouscule tout le
temps il perd pied et ça devient
difficile il veut fuguer il veut s'en
aller il reconnaît plus où il est donc
tout ça
nécessite quand même une grande
stabilité dans le dans l'espace et une
grande stabilité affective également
regarde tout
en compagnie de cette malade aujourd'hui
au stade de dépendance totale on mesure
à quel point l'environnement familial
est primordial en attendant les progrès
de la médecine il faut s'organiser à
défaut d'avoir un placement dans un des
trop rares établissements d'accueil
disponibles
les premiers signes de la maladie ce
sont des troubles de mémoire la personne
va perdre de plus en plus et de façon
définitive la mémoire rien à voir avec
les petits oublis quotidiens absolument
rien à voir avec les petits oublis
quotidiens ça ça nous arrive de très
jeunes de de d'oublier ou on a mis ses
clés ou
on a garé sa voiture des fois ou on met
toujours un petit moment pour pour
se recaler un peu ses idées mais ça ce
n'est absolument pas ça quoi c'est
vraiment la
des choses qui qui sortent qui
disparaissent de façon définitive de
notre mémoire
c'est une dégénérescence cérébrale donc
il y a une partie du cerveau qui ne
fonctionnera plus de façon définitive et
là la famille compte beaucoup je veux
dire pour éviter la déchéance
l'environnement affectif extrêmement
important
c'est pour ça que il est intéressant le
rôle de l'association c'est un petit peu
ça aussi c'est
soutenir les familles pour leur
permettre de garder les malades dans la
famille le plus longtemps possible
ce qui n'est pas simple du tout c'est
une maladie qui demande une prise en
charge quasi permanente 24 heures sur 24
donc c'est la famille qui fait face à ça
et si la famille ne pas faire ne peut
pas faire face mais il faut qu'elles
emploient des gens donc employer des
gens ça revient extrêmement cher donc il
faut que
on essaie au maximum de de faire en
sorte que les familles puissent
bénéficier d'aide ce qui n'est pas
toujours possible malheureusement
d'accord et ce qui ce qui nous pose
beaucoup de problèmes donc ce qui a ce
qu'il faut soutenir ces aidants la
soutenir ces accompagnants familiaux et
ça on a très très peu de moyens à
l'heure actuelle extrêmement peu de
moyens est-ce que vous savez quoi faire
pour justement avoir ses moyens mais je
crois qu'il faut il faut que nous
l'association on travaille à faire
prendre conscience de tout ça
au pouvoir public aux organismes qui qui
eux peuvent peut-être mettre en place
des choses qui permettront à la aux
familles d'être soulagée déjà à domicile
qui citron à toutes les familles pas
seulement un certain nombre dentaires
d'entre elles d'être aidé d'avoir des
gens qui interviennent pour la maison
pour les pour les tâches ménagères mais
aussi pour la garde à domicile des gens
qui puissent passer du temps à la maison
avec le malade et permettre à l'aidance
à ce moment-là de pouvoir sortir de
pouvoir faire ses courses de pouvoir
aller faire un peu de sport par exemple
ou de rencontrer des amis parce que il
faut savoir que les les gens qui
accompagnent ces malades et bien ils
sont coupés des autres
qu'on vienne à l'association en tant que
membre on compte à peu près actuellement
une cinquantaine d'adhérents
sympathisants famille de malades placées
ou famille de malades à domicile
et on est
6 membres du bureau à gérer
véritablement l'association est-ce que
vous avez rencontré beaucoup de
difficultés à la création de
l'association ça a été
surtout de
rencontrer les familles de faire que les
femmes
se
fasse connaître association réunion
Alzheimer s'occupe quand même de malades
donc nous on a absolument pas la
possibilité
d'aller vers les familles parce qu'il y
a le secret professionnel il faut on n'a
pas arrivé chez les gens soient nous
avons su que vous avez un malade
Alzheimer ça c'est pas possible donc on
attend que les familles s'adressent à
nous nos contacts et ça ça a été très
très difficile
pour de multiples raisons parce que
les familles sont
sont surchargés par les problèmes à
régler la prise en charge est très très
lourde
voilà et il y a aussi le contexte même
de la maladie il faut savoir que la
maladie d'Alzheimer touche
essentiellement de
cerveau donc les capacités
mentales et intellectuelle donc le
malade va perdre petit à petit toutes
ces facultés intellectuelles donc perdre
tous ses repères et là ça pose problème
parce que il ne devient il n'est plus un
être social donc c'est très gênant pour
les familles quoi il est difficile de
vivre à l'extérieur de de
continuer à vivre qu'on avait comment on
avait l'habitude de vivre quoi avec ces
malades donc on a organisé des
conférences on a organisé des rencontres
entre famille parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte également que quand les familles
était entre elles
échangées ça rompait l'isolement des
familles ça ça lui a permettait aussi
d'échanger des expériences
il y en a bon ben qui disent que moi
j'ai eu telle difficulté bon ben j'ai
essayé de faire comme ça comme ça je ne
sais pas si c'était bon mais en fait ça
a donné tel résultat et ça permet
justement à à chacun déjà de ne pas se
sentir seul face à ce problème ne pas se
sentir seul savoir qu'il y a d'autres
familles qui vivent ce type de problème
donc en s'unissant ben souvent
en psychologiquement ça fait du bien
ça crée des liens
l'autre problème c'est que la famille a
besoin aussi d'être beaucoup écouté donc
on a on tient des permanences deux fois
par semaine l'après-midi donc le mardi
après-midi le vendredi après-midi les
familles peuvent nous appeler et on les
écoute on essaie de scanner un petit peu
les besoins les plus urgents
ont laissé au maximum de les rencontrer
physiquement d'aller à domicile
d'avoir donc un contact physique qui qui
peut également
augmenter la confiance en la relation de
confiance entre les familles nous-mêmes
est-ce que vous travaillez en étroite
collaboration avec les médecins et on
peut avoir
des contacts avec les médecins quant à
pour essayer d'adapter justement la
prise en charge sociale on travaille
beaucoup avec les sociaux parce que ce
sont actuellement ce sont les
travailleurs sociaux qui installent qui
font donc l'évaluation des besoins des
familles qui installent une prise en
charge sociale c'est-à-dire
des
des aides ménagères pour soulager les
malades des gardes à domicile est-ce que
l'association allait subventionnée
absolument pas pour le moment on ne vit
qu'avec les cotisations des adhérents
donc les adhérents les familles ou même
les sympathisants on a un certain nombre
de personnes qui nous soutiennent parce
que ils estiment qu'il est important de
le faire et on nous n'avons eu jusqu'à
maintenant qu'une subvention de de
pouvoir publier ou alors l'association
française Alzheimer pourrait nous aider
mais comme je vous dis nous notre grand
souci à l'heure actuelle a été surtout
de rentrer en contact avec les familles
est-ce que vous trouvez que vous n'êtes
pas suffisamment aider est-ce que vous
trouvez que c'est une cause qui n'est
pas suffisamment reconnue à la Réunion
c'est déjà une pathologie qui n'était
pas vraiment reconnue et qui n'a pas on
n'a pas conscience encore véritablement
des difficultés que qu'entraînent cette
pathologie donc je crois qu'il faut du
temps il faut vraiment du temps et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'on se dit nous à
l'association il faut pas se décourager
c'est difficile on y arrive pas on ne
nous comprend pas etc mais je crois
qu'avec le temps on y arrivera